el día de hoy practicaremos de algo que
podría salvar tu vida o la de un ser
querido si te hacen conocidas las
siguientes imágenes en que se parecen
claro son etiquetas o avisos que diario
encontramos en cajas botellas empaques
de comida o en productos que usamos para
limpiar la casa pero que tienen que ver
con salvar una vida es recomendable
aprender a revisar la información que se
encuentra en las etiquetas de los
productos ya que nos orienta a usarlos
de manera adecuada y evitar lastimar nos
a nosotros mismos oa otra persona
empecemos por conocer el tipo de
información tablas cantidades o fechas
que podemos encontrar en uno de los
productos de consumo más común por
ejemplo un envase de leche
en la etiqueta podemos ver información
como fecha de caducidad la cual nos
indica hasta qué día podemos tomar la
leche tarde o temprano todo alimento se
descompone y si lo probamos nos podemos
enfermar así que antes de comer o tomar
algo busca esta fecha en las etiquetas
nutrientes y cantidades de azúcares
grasas vitaminas que contiene el
producto porciones o raciones que son
las tazas o vasos de leche que se
recomiendan beber las kilocalorías son
la cantidad de energía que este
productor le brinda a nuestro cuerpo
también podemos ver indicaciones como no
recomendado para personas alérgicas a la
lactosa la lactosa es un azúcar de la
leche que puede hacerle daño a algunas
personas por eso es importante que al
comprar o comer algún alimento siempre
lea la etiqueta para conocer qué
contiene y si es un producto
recomendable para ti las etiquetas
también presentan información sobre la
empresa que hizo el producto el lugar
donde se elaboró y recomendaciones de
uso
el siguiente ejemplo que probablemente
te sea familiar es la etiqueta de un
juguete aquí vemos el nombre del juguete
sus características los datos del
fabricante así como un número de serie
que nos dice qué número de juguete es de
todos los que se elaboraron en esa
ocasión ahora platicamos sobre unos
dibujos de seguridad que también
aparecen en este tipo de etiquetas
el primero se indica que el juguete o
producto cumple con todas las normas o
reglas de seguridad el segundo tiene la
carita de un niño con los números 0
guión 3 lo cual nos muestra que este
juguete no es adecuado para que menores
de 3 años de edad jueguen con él en
cuanto al cuidado del medio ambiente la
flecha verde significa que la envoltura
o empaque del juguete se puede utilizar
después de haberla depositado en la
basura el bote de basura con un tache
nos dice que las baterías o pilas del
juguete deben colocarse en un lugar
especial y no directamente en la basura
que desechamos a diario en nuestro caso
por último revisemos la cajita de una
medicina aquí encontramos el nombre de
la medicina y su fórmula química así
como la cantidad de pastillas o cápsulas
que contiene también nos informa sobre
los ingredientes de las que está hecha
la medicina al igual que el envase de
leche también tiene una fecha de
caducidad para conocer hasta qué día
podemos tomarla es muy importante que
siempre revises las recomendaciones para
tomar una medicina si respeta las
indicaciones que se dan estarás cuidando
tu salud y la de alguien más bien estoy
segura de que conoces más símbolos
además de los que ya mencionamos en este
vídeo te invito a que siga revisando la
información que se encuentra en varios
de los productos que compramos para
comer o utilizar en la casa y si tienes
alguna duda preguntar a tus papás o tus
maestros o alguna persona mayor